[Music]
that's top Louis I'm your uncle Jonathan
are you wearing a robe it's a kimono
here we are home sweet home
you're Luis I presume how was your trip
this old hag is my neighbor I'm relieved
to see you didn't inherit your uncle's
freakishly oversized head my God did
that withered purple skeleton just speak
you'll see it's quite different here
have a look around you're perfectly safe
safe as long as it's fed do you know
what a warlock is Lois a boy which I
think they're a little more than boy
widgets are you saying that you're a
warlock
please teach me please please okay have
it your way I can give you the right
books teach you the right spells but
that last one for Saturday that's up to
you
I don't want the creepy little runt sink
I wanted lucky shot
you've told Lois everything not
everything this house used to be owned
by another warlock
he's very wicked very powerful he left a
hidden clock in the walls we don't know
what it does except something horrible
three gums last time it was for what
happens when it gets down to one nothing
good that's for certain
we have to destroy the clock
so creepy you can't do this alone I can
help you
once is real magic I'll show you
shall we die he Punky's
[Applause]
you